after publishing my video the problem
with horror movies today many requested
that I tackle other genres as well
choosing another genre to dissect was
simple there's really no competition
action movies are suffering today and
not just in the way they're crafted but
at the box office as well
sure nearly every huge superhero film
and it's sequels rake in crazy money but
this video will focus more on pure
action films the issues with how they're
made and my suggestions for how to
improve them for this video I came up
with a simple process that action
filmmakers can employ and of course this
is just my opinion films are subjective
and my thoughts on this subject may not
resonate with everyone after listing
these steps I will discuss one final
requirement which i think is the
absolute most important and something
that action filmmakers seem to have
forgotten about entirely let's get
started number one the story this is
likely the most important aspect of all
filmmaking can we be invested in the
story yet it is a particular person stew
action films why is that action movie
plots have become very overused at this
point there's only so many times we can
see a really evil guy threatened to blow
up the world or some power-hungry baddie
take somebody's daughter audiences may
not be able to put their finger on it
but they know when they've seen
something special something unique that
actually gets their adrenaline pumping
let's talk about a film released in 1994
called speed this movie has one of the
best action plots of all time there's a
bomb on a bus if it goes under 50 miles
per hour it explodes there you go
instant two-hour thrill ride this is a
terrific concept because our hero is
constantly on edge he never has a second
to breathe and it gives the audience
something to be excited about every
single moment how about another little
Keanu Reeves film called the matrix this
movie has arguably one of the coolest
stories ever put up on the screen not
only was the action mind-blowing but the
film presented a world in which nothing
was what it seemed and the movie as
whole pulled the rug out from under all
of us action movies nowadays seem to
have lost the sense of presenting a
great story nearly every single one is a
recycled plot from another better film
taken three is essentially a cheap
watered-down version of the fugitive
RIPD is a rehashed attempt to recreate
the charm of men and black the legend of
Hercules is a shameless ripoff of
gladiator and 300 don't even get me
started with the endless string of
reboots and remakes action movies need a
story that is not only inhabited by
characters we care about but features a
plot that keeps the audience on the edge
of their seat in Raiders of the Lost Ark
Nazis want the Ark of the Covenant and
so does Indy and he'll do anything to
get it this is a story that lends to
action because it's a story that always
keeps our hero moving he's rarely given
the chance to stop so the film's
momentum never drags if your action film
doesn't have a plot that supports fast
paced filmmaking then you're doing
something wrong number 2 the hero an
action movie without someone to root for
is an unholy sin against cinema goers
our hero is the man or woman that we
desperately want to relate to when this
person is in peril we should be gripping
our hands tighter and tighter not
checking our watch wondering when the
credits will start let's take one of the
quintessential action heroes of our time
John McClane and compare the same
character from two different films die
hard and a good day to die hard in the
original film the character of John
McClane is not an invincible badass he's
actually a husband trying to reconnect
with his wife this is what his character
is doing in California he's not there to
fight terrorists he's just unfortunately
the only guy left the film takes its
time in the beginning to briefly present
a man afraid of flying a man having
difficulty with his marriage and
somebody we can actually care about so
when the action starts we want to see
him succeed because at this point it's
all he has left in his life and he is
all danaka Tom
Plaza has left he is but a pale shadow
of this man in die hard five there is
not even one single moment in the entire
runtime of this film in which our hero
isn't completely on top of things John
McClane was a lovable asshole in the
previous four films but in this
abomination he actually is an asshole
that guy you run into on the street that
makes you question humanity he punches a
pedestrian steals his car then crushes
many civilian vehicles including one
with an innocent woman inside the
previous Ford die hard films presented
McClane as a character who despite being
a total ass actually cared about people
that's why he became a cop die hard five
lost all sense of these things and the
movie sucked Indiana Jones is considered
one of the greatest movie heroes of all
time a lot of this is due to him just
being a regular guy this is something
that I want to cover towards the end of
this video and it is in my opinion the
most important part of presenting an
above-average action movie hero number
three the villain there's a saying that
your story is only as good as your
villain this is very true in my opinion
a compelling villain is generally the
polar opposite of our hero but perhaps
has one thing that connects them for
instance consider the t1000 from
Terminator 2 he and Arnold are both
terminators they're both connected by
John and Sarah Connor
and yet the t1000 is vastly superior
technologically and isn't governed by
the orders of John like Arnie is this
makes for a very interesting villain and
most importantly one that can actually
challenge our hero another prime example
is the Joker in the excellent crime
drama yes crime drama The Dark Knight if
brute strength money and power were the
deciding factors Batman would crush the
Joker in a split second but
unfortunately for Batman the Joker knows
every single button to push
psychologically to ruin our hero in the
film's best scene the Joker explains to
Batman how
similar they actually are saying he's
really just a freak like him for these
reasons the Joker is not only one of the
best villains of all time but serves as
an example for all writers out there on
how to craft a powerful antagonist
another very important aspect of getting
the villain right is giving him
motivation that we can understand so
often the bad guy is portrayed as a
cartoon character who just wants money
the best villains are the ones we can
actually understand consider the sheep
from Casino Royale to this day he
remains my favorite Bond villain why
because we can actually understand where
he's coming from he's at the end of his
rope financially he absolutely requires
money because his life is being
threatened by a powerful organization
he's not some faceless head of some
powerful place who continuously strokes
his cat he's actually someone who not
only challenges bonds psychologically
but a human being a great example of
this is the one and only Darth Vader
next to the Emperor he's the most evil
guy in the galaxy or is he in reality
he's a person who watched his entire
life crumble lost his children and the
majority of his body but it's his
connection with Luke that made those
original three films so unforgettable
and the humanity under that helmet that
made him so intriguing number four the
stunts an action movie without great
stunts is like a comedy without laughs
however before the filming can even take
place it's important to cast an actor
who actually does some let's talk about
Tom Cruise this man is the best example
of a hugely famous artist who
legitimately wants the audience to have
a good time and someone who recognizes
that actually seeing the action hero
doing these amazing things makes not
only the experience better but the film
better from the very first Mission
Impossible
Cruise has proven himself to be an
excellent sport and has continued to do
stunts so insane
he's essentially the American Jackie
Chan in most action films when the hero
does something dangerous the camera is
positioned behind him
so that we are unable to tell that a
stunt double has replaced the actor
during the entire Burj Khalifa scene in
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol our
palms sweat because Cruise is actually
out there suspended from a line some
audience members assume they're looking
at CGI yet are unable to explain in
words why the scene was so great well
simply put it's actually happening the
best and most entertaining action scenes
in history revolve around breathtaking
stunt work and are performed by brave
men and women who have a serious love of
their craft actors like Harrison Ford
and Keanu Reeves have been famously very
dedicated to what they call physical
acting not necessarily death-defying
stunts but performances infused with
adrenaline that provide us with the
knowledge that our favorite action
heroes can actually do the things they
are depicted on screen doing an actor
who is unwilling to get involved with
the stunts puts a strain on the director
it causes him to incorporate more cuts
and angle changes to his vision than
perhaps he originally planned on this
can be very frustrating not just for him
but the audience it's vastly important
to cast actors who actually are invested
in the action scenes and who want the
audience to have as much enjoyment as
possible number 5 the camerawork dear
Lord this is what I've been waiting to
talk about you all knew it was coming
shaky-cam fucking shaky-cam
at some point someone somewhere told
Hollywood that people like incoherent
incompetent camerawork blinding the
audience with multiple cuts and
assaulting us with nothing but a barrage
of sound effects that are supposed to
subconsciously tell us that something is
happening on-screen there is but one
director out there who uses shaky cam
successfully Paul Greengrass the Bourne
Ultimatum is considered by many to be
one of the best action movies of recent
years and yet it is littered with shaky
cam so why does it work many directors
now use shaky cam as a cheap quick way
to film a scene between two actors who
have not won
single clue how to pull off a stunt so
it's used as a way to mask poor stunt
work other directors actually do it
because they like it
I guess some of the worst examples of
this technique are every film directed
by Olivier Megaton his action scenes are
extremely difficult to follow filled
with endless cuts and angle changes that
serve no purpose other than to make our
eyes sting Greengrass doesn't use shaky
cam to hide anything it's clear
throughout the film that Damon and the
other stunt people are very invested in
the action scenes and the seamless
editing and use of wides at just the
right moment make this apparent rob
Cohen's direction of the final fight
scene in Alex Cross is so unimaginably
awful that I struggle to comprehend how
it was approved it's very easy to look
at this scene and assume that these
actors are unable to perform a
convincing fight and that Coen is using
this technique in an attempt to cover up
their inability to sell convincing stunt
work yet a quick look at this brief but
memorable fight scene from another
Matthew Fox film called Speed Racer
shows us the exact opposite so clearly
the man can do stunts
so why film your action scene like
there's an earthquake going on on the
set Speed Racer was directed by the
Wachowski to people who clearly
understand the art of an action scene
take for instance the final fight
between neo and Smith i watch and drool
at the fluidity of the camerawork and
how beautifully it glides across the
subway filming these talented actors and
excellent wide angles letting our eyes
soak in the moments Keanu Reeves recent
film John wick is another excellent
example of how to do it right this movie
was directed by veteran stuntman who
made their love of the genre
infectiously obvious with the vivid
lighting and terrific camerawork
something people often confuse is
handheld cam for shakey cam these are
two very different things a film like
Saving Private Ryan used handheld camp
two beautiful results and a glowing
example of handheld cams defectively is
the nightclub scene in collateral
handheld cam is simply a shot that isn't
locked down by a tripod or any other
device oftentimes the cameraman is
physically holding the camera and this
creates an unpredictability to the
camera work and with unpredictability
being a major theme of collateral it was
the perfect choice shaky cam is
literally just the cameraman shaking the
camera back and forth on purpose and
even scarier sometimes the shakey cam
effect is even enhanced in post with
more vibration added foreign films have
been a consistent example of how to do
it right the raid 2 features Swift
cinematography and actors who've clearly
trained tirelessly to make the action
look convincing but there is a danger to
excessive choreography and fight
training that danger is that the battle
will more closely resemble a dance than
a fight this is what I fear happened
with Revenge of the Sith
the final lightsaber battle is cool and
all but it was so flashy and well
practiced that rarely throughout the
fight do we ever get the sense that
either of them are actually in danger
the excuse has been made by some very
forgiving Star Wars fans that these are
Jedi in their prime and they're using
the force at such a fast level that they
can successfully predict the other's
movements that's fine and all but that
doesn't change the fact that they don't
appear worried or concerned even
remotely one of the most important
things to choreograph is not just the
hits kicks and blocks but the acting
that happens in between them this is
something that Jackie Chan excels at he
is a brilliant physical actor and one
that understands that it's not just
about the action it's about the drama
that happens in between the action too
often today action scenes appears so
well staged that we can often sit back
and watch the punches fly without being
concerned for our hero this leads me to
my final and most important point the
vulnerability of our hero let's talk
about a movie called Lucy which was
entertaining at time
but that was mostly because it had a
sleek look and Scarlett Johansson is
effortlessly watchable but one of my
largest complaints with the film was
that once Lucy was able to unlock the
recesses of her brain there was not a
single person left alive able to
challenge her she took on hordes of
people without even blinking an eye
due to her invincibility this made the
action scenes tensionless an action hero
should have something about him or her
that makes us relate to them a
vulnerability of humanity we need to
fear for our hero's survival let's
compare the matrix to its sequel The
Matrix Reloaded in the first film during
the climactic battle between neo and
Smith the hits felt real dust flies off
their chests blood trickles from Neos
mouth there are legitimate moments
throughout where you wonder if neo can
actually win this is a vulnerable hero
we feel like we could be like this man
in the Matrix Reloaded we are given a
series of fight scenes with dazzling
choreography wondrous camerawork and no
sense of pain neo has literally become a
superhero
and nearly all tension has drained from
the action the hits feel powerless
the endless parades of Smith's appear
like balloon people being smacked into
the air like toys the best fight scene
in that film is the chateaux sword fight
and largely because there are moments
throughout that neo genuinely appears a
little bit concerned the sunglasses also
have something to do with it by taking
away our hero's eyes it's even harder to
connect with him
consider Mel Gibson in the first Lethal
Weapon awesome badass cool crazy guy
right well sure but he's also a man
mourning the loss of his wife and
contemplating suicide the character of
Martin Riggs has an emotional Center and
his friendship with Murtaugh made it all
the better as already mentioned John
McClane is the ultimate everyman action
hero throughout the action he's always
more concerned about his children his
wife and the hostages that how many
people he can blow up the quintessential
vulnerable action hero is Indiana Jones
observe the brilliant
truck chase scene from Raiders why is
this scene so perfect
besides the incredible stunt work John
Williams pounding score and a live wire
direction its success is due to the
physical journey of Indy throughout the
scene once he gets inside the truck and
has the upper hand on the guards he then
gets shot in the arm and a smart ear
will notice Williams score instantly
changes at this moment to a continuously
building theme that tells us it just got
serious
one relentless soldier gets the best of
Indy pummeling him in the gunshot wound
he then tosses Indy through the
windshield putting him inches away from
being run over this is what I call the
breaking point moment most great action
films have this the moment where our
hero is at his lowest point and has no
choice but to dig his way out and
somehow come out on top in John
McTiernan x' predator it's this
incredible moment after all of Arnie's
team has been killed and he realizes
he's the only one left Alan Silvestri's
amazing score reflects the horror his
character is feeling as he realizes he
has no one left but himself this is why
watching indeed pull himself under the
truck then getting dragged behind it
only to come around and knock the crap
out of the soldier is so enthralling
we've seen our hero taken to the
breaking point and then come out on top
it makes my adrenaline rush every single
time the last crusade had this moment as
well Indy hanging on the edge of the
tank getting beaten by a shovel but
eventually just at the last second he
climbs back up Temple of Doom had it too
when mola Ram nearly pulls Indy's heart
out near the finale you know what film
doesn't have the breaking point moment
you guessed it
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull you might
argue that there was about five seconds
during Indies fight with the Russian
where he crawled on the ground briefly
but essentially Indy remained perfectly
on top of things throughout the entire
film there was never a moment where we
feared for Indy survival like in the
previous three and that is just one of
the reasons why in d4 didn't succeed so
basically our heroes need to be
relatable in some way you'll find that
even the
best superheroes are the ones that have
something about them that make them
human something about them they're
hiding or perhaps it's a belief system
they're harboring that they are coming
to realize is false another discussion
I'd love to have is entirely about the
pg-13 rating but that's for another
video my sincere hope is that filmmakers
who are making action films can perhaps
use this video as a guide on what to
avoid if you are planning an action film
currently please consider these points
because I strongly believe they will
make your film better and if you are
concerned with the current state of
action films please share this video
maybe we can make a difference so what
do you guys think on this subject and if
you missed my video on the problem with
horror movies today there will be an
annotation for it here shortly thank you
as always so much for watching guys and
if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes